you
hi everyone is Jerry the elephant trap
is a trap for black out of the Queens
gambit declined if white is not careful
just five or six moves into the game
they can find themselves down to minor
piece and only have a pawn to show for
it so here's how it works
d4 d5 c4 e6 the Queens gambit declined
in just a quick summary of this trap
really revolves around this d5 square
white is there to put pressure on it
black is there to defend additional
pressure on move three additional
defense and even more pressure now on
this d5 square only in this case
indirectly since this night is now
pinned to the Queen and now after Knight
B to d7 this is where white can simply
go wrong thinking that they could win
upon on this d5 square now this move
right here may very well be steering
into what's known as the Cambridge
Springs defense for example after e3 c6
Knight f3 Queen a5 would denote the
Cambridge Springs defense activating the
queen pinning the knight there might be
some tricks along this fifth rank but we
don't quite get there as soon as Knight
B to d7 is played this is where white
can go wrong in the following way on
move five C takes D which is fine
II take ste but now I'm this sixth move
if white takes on d5 they simply fall in
for the elephant trap I'm not quite sure
how it got its name but Knight takes d5
is a serious blunder because black can
simply take the knight give up the Queen
but only temporarily
since Bishop b4 check will win the white
queen back in short order Queen d2 is an
only move the Queen is pinned you can
take her right away or simply recognize
she's going nowhere
pick up the bishop and soon enough after
the smoke clears what do we have while
black is simply up a minor piece and
white only has a pawn to show for it
King to e2 is the only way to maintain
defense of the Queen but now comes the
devastating ponte snipe under promoting
to a night with check this is all very
important